steven coached with him the last two  years there's johnson with a miss  and the rebounds on the floor cousins  couldn't get it going to be a jump ball  sterling brown and cauley stein  i don't know you know boogie cousins  when he's in the middle of something  he's the guy to  [Applause]  he's the guy that's going to stand up  for his teammates but he definitely  pushed  did they call a double take on that i'm  not sure but right there is where  cousins pushed  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  we got a jump ball no worse for the wear  violations  good save by cousins and he just  boguards his way right through the pack  how are you going to guard him with  brunson he said get out of my way  kid what what they call  what happened did they call a foul on  cousins they got a timeout  for the mavericks and they teased all  the cousins and threw them out of the  game  technical that's the second called on  boogie cousins and he's  out of the game time out  on the court